there is a kid
he went a little bit viral over the
weekend I want to make him go much more
viral I am so impressed with this kid
he was a freshman at a liberal High
School
and
I'm sure that his school is a lot like
your school I'm sure that his school is
a lot like schools all around the
country
liberal uh
racist sexist in all the opposite ways
that that we're told that the public
institutions are
and he said enough and he showed up to
his school board and he gave an oratory
worthy of at least getting him elected
to congress if not president already at
the age of 14. take a listen
hi my name is Brad Taylor and I just
finished my freshman year at rhs I've
been a part of district 196 schools now
for 10 years and I'm going to give you a
glimpse today of what's actually going
on inside these schools despite the
board's attempt to deny it district 196
schools are quickly becoming a place
where promoting activism is actually
more important than promoting education
I'll take
I'll take you back to my first day at
rhs this fall the principal came out and
gave us a heartfelt speech about
equality and standing together
he began to list countless races such as
Latino Asian expressing how much they
matter and how important they are but
never once did he mention a race or
identity that reflects me or half the
kids that were in the class
my honors government teacher I'm not
going to say his name but he's mentioned
that Democrats care more about all
people while Republicans only care about
themselves
and he's also inferred to us that
socialism is better than democracy he
even had a statue he had a statue of a
socialist leader in his classroom have
been approached by multiple teachers who
have told me in private that they just
want to say that they agree with me and
they support me standing up but they
can't say it in front of the class for
fear of being
disciplined by the administration in
some way or losing their jobs now due to
all these instances I've mentioned and
many more that I can't fit in this
five-minute speech I've decided to leave
this district and continue school on a
private Christian School online but I
will never stop believing that everybody
has value no matter their skin color or
personal beliefs and it's a shame that
you're not going to be able to say that
I was an alumni of rhs in District 196.
thank you
preach preach man what can this kid run
for I I what is he 15 he just finished
his freshman year in high school I guess
it's a little too young for congress but
let me know when you're ready to run kid
I can't wait to donate I can't wait to
go vote
beautiful that that kid showing more
clarity and maturity
and courage
then
any and not only any other student at
the school any teacher at the school
he's saying these teachers come up to me
they say you're right I agree with you
but I don't want to lose my job
how sad is that you'll say Hey you 15
year old thanks for doing what I a grown
adult am unwilling to do
love it
and it presents a political opportunity
for republicans
we have control of a lot of states
around the country right now this is a
great opportunity to push school choice
and why should we push school choice
because the Democrats rely on the
schools as a major Power Center
school choice is the easiest way to
weaken their grip on that power and it's
a very powerful Power Center because
classrooms are crystal balls that show
you what your country is going to look
like in 20 years shapes the very
malleable minds of little kids
school choice is the biggest threat to
that
I've been mentioning it in my new state
of Tennessee which I love so much this
would be a great opportunity the
governor campaigned on school choice
he's obviously very supportive of it
we've got I don't know like three
Democrats in the whole legislature the
the Republicans outnumber the Democrats
three to one four to one in the house in
the Senate let's get it done guys this
is a great opportunity you have to be on
the offense or you will be on the
defense it's like a business
anyone who's ever run a business or
worked for a business for that matter
will know that a business is either
growing or dying
businesses don't just stay the same it
doesn't work that way
you've got to be growing or dying you've
got to be moving forward or you're going
to be pushed backward
so let's do it while we've got power
let's just put that pedal to the metal
and let's give more kids the opportunity
that this young man has
to go pursue more edifying educational
opportunities and
perhaps even more important weaken the
Stranglehold of these crazy libs that
they have on public education so that we
can
create better schools in the future
so that we can go back get a little more
power in public education and turn it
toward the good the true and the
Beautiful not the ugly the false and the
wicked as it is now wonderful story out
of Florida yesterday which is that they
executed a murderer
Governor Ron DeSantis refused to Pardon
this guy his name is Donald dilbeck
career criminal and he was executed this
is a guy
who was convicted of the 1990 murder of
a woman felam van mother in a Tallassee
mall parking lot and he he was only able
to murder her because he had escaped
from prison where he was at the time
serving a life sentence for killing a
sheriff's deputy in 1979. this is a bad
bad dude
now this was the first execution in
Florida in more than three years
it was the 100th execution since the
Supreme Court allowed the practice to
resume in 1975 and Ron DeSantis is going
pretty hard after this he's been he's
been a tough Law and Order kind of
governor and he's saying well if you
kill somebody we're going to kill you
back
the final words of this man Donald
dilbeck are what really to me tell the
whole story
so after the family of the woman that he
murdered wrote they said 11 932 days ago
Donald dilbeck brutally killed our
mother we were robbed of years of
memories with her and it has been very
painful ever since however the execution
has given us some closure we're grateful
to Governor DeSantis for carrying out
the sentence what were the final words
of this murderer he said I know I hurt
people when I was young I really messed
up but I know Ron DeSantis has done a
lot worse he's done a lot worse than
murder two people one of whom was a
mother he's taken a lot from a lot of
people I speak for all men women and
children he's put his foot on our necks
Ron DeSantis and other people like him
can suck our
that he names an appendage which I won't
I won't name those are his final words
Ron DeSantis can suck my appendage and
my conclusion from that is
this guy didn't learn anything
this murderer this double murderer
guy who kills a mother in Cold Blood in
a parking lot
32 and a half years he was in prison he
didn't learn anything
one of the arguments against the death
penalty is we need to give these guys a
time to change their mind to repent to
rehabilitate first of all hanging
concentrates the mind I sometimes think
a shorter time scale to consider
repentance is better than a longer one
but even look at the long one 32 and a
half years wasn't enough to change this
guy's mind those are the final words he
wants to go out on doesn't learn a damn
thing in prison doesn't seem to have any
remorse whatsoever
see you buddy the Civil Authority does
not wield The Sword in vain and people
need to know the public needs to know
that there are consequences to bad
actions this is basic incentives if you
don't punish bad behavior you're going
to get more bad behavior if you don't
reward good behavior then you're less
likely to get more of that good behavior
basic incentives and some of those basic
government incentives include the Noose
or in this case the lethal injection
it's music Monday baby we got to get on
over to the member block uh Ben Davies
has given me a song that he he wants me
to throw all of my pop culture prowess
onto and I'm willing to do that we will
see you there if you're not a member why
not are you just one of those Hoy polloi
out there perusing this show on YouTube
for free you got to go to dailywire.com
use code Knowles at checkout to get two
months free on all annual plans
[Music]
foreign